can we start the same in a different way
yeah
things are getting crazy here Oh No okay
come in here okay I'm gonna squat you
how you just caught me okay ready all
right this is it this is my workout
because she's a worker all right all
right Jonathan all right [ __ ] you could
[Laughter]
good technique that was very socially
important to see the technique that's so
impressive and you you work out too well
I just started working with the trainer
Harley Pasternak FMLA and he he has me
on a cleanse and a reset which there's
two things that happened one lose weight
I've actually so I'm down which I say is
this I'm down to 210 which I have not
been but it's it's not just that it also
allows you to rediscover the smells of
all the other food you're not having
that are amazing cookies not for you I
haven't talked to you guys in a while
it's been a bit lots of happen since
then and things are good and a new show
forever homes forever home is the the
next part of our property brothers
adventure it's really in talking with
our fans we love our fans yeah do
everything for them and we renovate
almost 45 houses a year for fans and so
they're saying on social media you know
property brothers is for people who are
buying but what about all of us who
already own a house that just isn't
quite working for us but we love it we
wanted to dig into the heart of the
story as to what made people fall in
love with a home and yeah we can fix all
the function stuff that's not working
but we want you to fall in love with the
home again you know you just see that
use the word heart you know finding the
heart of your home so what do you do do
you go into the house they tell you
what's wrong with the house and then you
kind of figure out how to make it at
home yes you know I used to get made fun
of because they said I was the Heartless
brother because I would go and make fun
of everything in the home and this time
we want the homeowners to tell us like
walk us through how you use the home and
sometimes it's the kids will have four
year old kids who walk us in like I hate
that there's no dishwashers because I'm
the dishwasher also on top of that too
when people are you
because the parents think because they
own the house they're a little bit like
well they're protecting things whatever
in the kids are like nope let's cut the
BS yeah this is terrible but I mean the
big thing for us with these houses
people live in them they have been
living them you know for our show you
could be in your house for 60 years
you're still eligible but when you live
in a house you know what's not working
for you and so that's what we're coming
in to fix cherish all the memories that
you have there and give you a space that
you can love moving forward so will you
learn techniques on how you're doing the
renovations in these houses
make your other shows yes so we're kind
of thinking the best of all the
different shows because you know we have
the fun moments like you see on brother
vs. brother we have the really dramatic
makeovers the before-and-afters like on
property brothers but that's the part
that I think we're really focusing in on
is the heart of the story really
following the story of the homeowners
and we have every different kind of
story command in fact our brother was
one of the first episodes we reminisce
fiancee Anna Lee we renovated their home
and in Vegas and it just turned out so
cool so differently different that
they're personalized her her design
aesthetic is we call it bubblegum chic
and his was Manimal istic and so we
found a way to blend but for whoever the
family is if we really focus in and
because I'm not touring new houses for
them to buy mm-hmm I'm more hands-on
again on the construction side like we
used to be back in finally yeah we got
drew doing the work again get your
secret your nozzle pretty good
yes so what makes a house a home you
know it really comes down to the fact
like a house is just a collection of you
know studs and windows and doors and
things like that but a home is where you
get you get through those doors and you
can just sigh a big sigh of relief and
say well I'm gonna recharge my batteries
because this is where I want to make
memories yeah it's not the physical
house that people fall in love with it's
you know always it's not always that it
you know it could be the neighborhood it
could be that moment you remember back
when you're measuring your kids on the
doorway the doorframe it's all those
little things we really want to cherish
and help people love the rest of that it
really is what's inside that counts your
friends and you you worked on houses in
GTA yes we're doing 30 mm you know we
did eight for the show in Vegas the
actual pilot for forever home was shot
in San Francisco and that's a cool thing
too is we're saying where we are we're
saying what city were in and also we're
still casting in Toronto right now so if
anybody wants to go to property brothers
calm you may just be on the show well
maybe we should go to my house yeah I
can do though you have been asking us
for 14 years make it more of a home I
have a few rooms that doesn't even have
furniture yet we do Fitness use it
there's no furniture in that room I do
what will will sort of give you the
ultimate decked out workout area okay
and then we'll also put furniture in
your bedroom and living room okay and
happy anniversary
thank you just what do you know so
Lyndon our new Star Wars people so may
the fourth was our wedding and so we
just we just had that and I love Linda
she loves me more than me I love her so
does that mean making a home is having
kids and building the family is this an
exclusive and we do want to have kids I
mean even yesterday we were hanging out
with with our nephews our nieces and
nephews we've got a lot of time with
them it's it makes us want to be parents
and so I look forward to that happening
one day yeah isn't it weird though when
you bring up the whole you think of
having kids because you're essentially
asking if they're having sex it's weird
it's weird if you ask that I always get
socially
having sex no can I say that you're
working out right now so that's your
yeah oh yeah that's so much this
conversations going somewhere our home
he'll finally have sex well that's I
mean my forever home has like a fifty
Shades forget it
are you looking for love is that what
you're trying to tell me right now yeah
like I'm not close I took the last year
and I call like 2019 is my year of no BS
I I I'm focusing on me I'm focusing on
getting you know my my career in a place
where like now you know our schedule is
getting a lot better so I can actually
you know what and do things it wasn't
easy for the last number of years I'd
have I mean there's some years where I
only had six or seven days off the
entire year and so it's it's nice now
that you know well we're getting a good
place we love what we do but we also
have to make sure that we have a strong
balance between our work life and what
we do for others and then also taking
care of ourselves and that's why I'm
excited to see how I've always been the
health nut but now to see Jonathan has
definitely been working out more he's
been eating really well and we're
actually getting out and doing some fun
activities that's pretty cool see this
love is what a home is all about yeah
the support I'm so excited for you guys
catch up again okay oh yeah
you